the worst is apparently behind us
but when it comes to the food shop the
cost of living is still biting Sally a
single mom from ilford says she's
struggling to keep up for me I think it
doesn't it haven't gone down it's just
going up and up and up you have family
you have kids you need to feed them it's
not only the food they have like you
need extra extra things that you have to
buy for them your fridge have to have
like healthy food and everything so all
your wages are going there
didn't go up but the food is just taking
all my wages it's tough on everyone it's
a common concern you come today he said
t-bound 50. you come back tomorrow it's
2.70 and he's like a slap on your face
and I've come across a couple of people
that stopped to get their shopping done
and then you have to talk them off which
is really sad but there are some
glimmers of Hope official figures show
that the headline rate of inflation has
fallen for three consecutive months now
after peaking at 11.1 in October it fell
to 10.1 percent in January but food
prices kept rising robustly at a rate of
16.7 percent the Figures were in line
with forecasts published by the bank of
England which thinks inflation will fall
consistently over the coming months
the rate of inflation may be slowing but
that will provide very little relief to
households who are already struggling
with their everyday costs
food prices for example are still
climbing at their fastest Pace in
decades that will soon start slowing but
it doesn't mean prices will be coming
down from where they already are
further up the supply chain wholesalers
say they are battling with costs from
energy to raw materials which are
forcing them to keep prices high for
prices to start coming down I think
we're looking at the back end of the
Sierra if I'm honest I don't see and
certainly none of my colleagues in the
business see a change in the next four
four to five months so we are looking
really probably six months ahead for any
relief for consumers for the moment then
things shouldn't get any worse but they
aren't getting any better either garprit
nawan Sky News